it's it's all possible do what you love
and if you go about it the right way you
could do it all you know you gotta just
really be strategic with with your plays
I like just staying in neutral bro you
gotta just be like this bro they gonna
love you love you or hate you I'm not
late no one be in my lane or in my way
too it's like it's like being traffic
bro you're supposed to be in the fast
lane or you got a big ass diesel in
front of you you're just so comfortable
like [__] it when you could easily like
tilt over it and you got a whole [__]
Lane in front of you to take off and
[__] be ahead of everyone you know or
you could just get caught up behind the
door you could just get caught and
that's being comfortable that's being
comfortable bro but yeah
and just [__] yeah take off
thank you